I think if there were an exact science
as to what will hit then writers would
be making it all over the place I think
really like I'm going to tell you from
being a studio executive for the number
of years that I was and still being a
writing instructor at NBC and studying
pilots in knowing that you know
Hollywood doesn't know exactly what's
going to hit like there's rolling it out
there and praying that middle America is
going to show up and and you can have
you know I think if you were to survey a
bunch of studio executives at the
beginning of each season and say what
shows do you think are going to be the
breakout hit vs what shows are theirs
you know it's hit or miss it is like you
the show's like when you take a show
like transparent I am sure there were so
many doubts about that show and would it
hit yet you take someone like Jill
Soloway who could six feet under and you
know that she has a track record and you
know it's based on emotional truth and
you look at the current climate climate
in the world and it was everything just
happens together and so and I think that
happens a lot like I definitely think
there are shows that the first season
like blows people's mind and so
therefore all these expectations isn't
it on the second season and that is a
large expectation you know so you've
seen that a lot where the first season
is amazing and then for some reason the
second season is all short get and is
that because the writing becomes sale
it's not clear I believe that that
because the series concept wasn't set
in a strong enough way to understand
what season two three and four work and
I've seen shows like say for example
lost loss was developed oddly enough
it's spelling even though it went to ABC
because the writer spelling was going to
do it with ABC but then the writer
spelling had the script didn't come in
in the way that ABC wanted it so they
got Damon Lindelof and JJ Abrams who had
overall deals there now lost to my
understanding did not have a clear sense
of what the show was going to be beyond
the first season and it worked and that
was okay because the concept was set up
in a strong enough way that we cared and
we wanted to return and then the way it
evolves each season was mind-blowing
because we were with them we the setup
of the series ark was strong enough even
though there wasn't clarity on what the
other seasons were going to be versus
other shows where you could steal that
they have one really strong season in
them and are they going to be able to
keep up with that and I think the
mistake that is made that leads to the
show not succeeding is that season two
those too far away from the core concept
that was set up